ciao ragazzi benvenuti a una puntata di
cucina buttata pietro di me vedete la
nuova cucina di cucina buttata avevo
parlato tanto della vecchia cucina e
abbiamo seguito i vostri consigli li
abbiamo uniti a quello che comunque era
il nostro gusto nostra visione che
abbiamo cercato di creare un qualcosa
che piacesse a noi di sicuro ma spero
anche a voi quindi fateci sapere quanto
siete piace oppure no con la
consapevolezza che se direte che non vi
piace io mi fionderà dal quinto piano
detto ciò su instagram qualche giorno fa
vi ho chiesto quale fosse il vostro
snack dolce preferito ne sono arrivati
un botto ma a vincere è stato il kinder
cereali a quanto pare è la merendina
preferita dagli italiani ha un problema
che hanno un sacco di snack dolci
rettangolare
italiani ma enrico pericolose bene ma
immaginate se un kinder cereali in
realtà non fosse così ma fosse così
addirittura come l'altra minoranza di
italiani
oggi io prenderò questo kinder cereali e
cercherò di ingrandirlo renderlo proprio
il più simile possibile ma si può fare
anche con altre cose che avevano un
amico non contro credo se questa
chiedere per poter far richiederci reali
però ho fatto dei calcoli lo prima
misurato mettendo vicino 5 penney
infilati enrico quello che creeremo sarà
inter celia l'ho né di 44 cm virgola
serve il 21 è alto
4,1 totale di
2,652 kg di cioccolato per riuscire a
creare il nostro kinder cereali che ci
sfami durante il pomeriggio questo è più
o meno tutto il cioccolato al latte
questo è il cioccolato bianco e tipo
mezzo chilo bando alle ciance devo
iniziare subito a lavorare una paura per
oggi ma iniziato e giuro mi devo tenterà
il cioccolato come ho fatto le uova di
pasqua ragazzi al fallimento allora
secondo i calcoli adesso come cazzo di
fare calcoli
vergata che gli alberi staccato due rate
relative al papa per la citta la
partenza è tutta per ammazzare così è
stato
forza ragazzi come
vedi la cosa proiettata sullo schermo
guglielmo non sarà mai in grado di farlo
ma lo stai facendo a bagnomaria si
quanti millenni ci vorranno per
sciogliere tuttavia devo temperarlo
questo cioccolato che deve raggiungere
temperatura quanto di un po era partito
con due alla seconda il
labour teoricamente non dovrebbe toccare
l'arte ma sta toccando ferro fallito ma
sento guardi il mondo alla nostra destra
è il mondo ideale che dovrebbe essere
cucina buttata ma che non sarà mai
quindi con gli al motu non girarti marte
che sapete dov'è l'inferno davanti
americane io lo vedo allora la tecnica è
in questo modo mi fa meno male che così
perché io l'ho visto fare a craco bravi
a farlo di polso è fatto così così si
fatica di me non è proprio visto che la
so se tu l'hai vista su youporn creare
sto movimento però
sono 50 gradi sono a 50 gradi che si
faccia entrare lo scatolone fabbrico
onesto
sono delle scatole una chitarra vi
faccio vedere come si fa da quando suona
di tanto la scusa al 44 44 più 40 anni
fa ce lo siamo giocati questo marco 40
per copia vorrei consigliare a chi ci
segue di giocarsi questi numeri non
andava per sicuramente essere l'anno
nell'estate domenica è uscito lotto
1a qui nel blog ha ora muciaccia ha
messo più tempo a tagliare una scatola
che a temperare il cioccolato male
sbagliato
consiglio è una scatola chiusa ragazzi
veramente mi ricorda un po l'epico video
dove abbiamo costruito il macchinario
dello zucchero filato in realtà
basterebbe benissimo che uno prenda uno
scatolone più grande però noi abbiamo
preso direttamente quello col quale era
arrivata la smerigliatrice ragazzi fate
sapere qua sotto quali sono altre cose
che vorreste vedere i giganti questa
sarà la dimensione del nostro kinder
cereali per i ora e sarà alcun bravo
restauratore sta improvvisando tutte le
professioni della storia dell'umanità
oh santo cielo edward mani di forbice è
diventato
a questo punto è sottomesso la carta
vedetelo foderato perché non è che posso
mettere il cioccolato direttamente a
contatto col cartone e dei denti
affilatissimi una cosa te la riconosco
in questo video di oggi i ragazzi è il
2027 tutto ciò non hai ancora spiegato
che cos'è quel pulsante rosso sbaglio
questo qui un pulsante particolare
scoprirete cosa fa quando lo prelevò
perfetto 27 gradi lo rimettiamo qui
riportiamo a 31 vado
dove secondo te vi riuscirà a poche
volte ho creduto così tanto in un mio
progetto voglio continuare a sognare
secondo i miei calcoli sono 440 grammi
di cioccolato bianco sto parlando acqua
a tutto bene coi hermanos in ottobre ai
telespettatori non so se ve lo stiate
chiedendo da in sé puntata per la pianta
alle spalle di guglielmo è proprio la
pianta di marijuana
carlo è buonissimo io salvatore di latte
materno
guardatelo ma che adesso vi faccio
vedere come si fa allora io ho fatto dei
calcoli pouhon ridere ho fatto dei
calcoli con dietro la scritta r nella
lista c'era scritto 66 il gr riso
soffiato la mia g effettivamente
sembrava un 9 gianmarco ha preso
669 r che non so che cosa sia su punto
il riso soffiato
669 g di orzo pera e per fortuna quando
ho letto
1540 gr di cioccolato non ha letto
15.409 io ragazzi ho i miei disturbi ma
ma questo non sa scrivere al journal che
ho appreso orzo perlato non orzo perlato
soffiato ho parlato
secco
non c'entra tom one hai fatto dei
calcoli veramente fuori di testa
528 grammi di latte condensato
vai che le serate de giuli al vaglio
giriamo
mardan e che ma pazzo né che sta facendo
dove si impasta con le mani o vai così a
seguitemi è un nuovo calcolo e devo fare
per poter fare stalking cereali gigante
devo riuscire ad avere meno pressioni
totale quindi io non sono pazzo dov'è
cosa là dove
c'era
tra le tue carta da forno guarda da dare
la cucina siamo passati a dei pappagalli
renzo carini vedete vado a comporre come
se fosse un torrone troppo spesso forse
se proprio tanto se fai adesso a portare
quello di neri nel
presidente forse so come farà
anche il massaggiatore guglielmo dal
centro estetico
pezzetto dopo pezzetto pezzetto 9 meglio
lanciato sono arrivato a questo punto
non posso fare il salto non voglio
emozionare pubblico io voglio solamente
riuscire a fare una cosa bene nella mia
vita voglio fare fatto bene per una
volta non è più quello di una volta
non me l'aspettavo in dimmi se non ti è
venuto bene
vado a mettere al volo nuovo in frigo
scusate che qui oggi sciolgo più
cioccolato di quanto su breaking bad lo
sai che sciolgono le anfetamine ed anche
da meno io voglio essere antico voglio
che sia identico io sto lavorando al
massimo delle mie capacità per tirarvi
fuori un kinder cereali gigante che non
si dica di guglielmo quando fa le cose
giganti scrive xl quando in realtà esse
sui siti di incontri io non sono quel
tipo se io scrivo xl è perché xl il mio
cazzo di killer seriali fare quello
stradino faceva un pò prima ad
affrescare la cappella sistina
adesso io questo lo metto a nanna e ci
vediamo domani mattina ciao ragazzi è il
giorno dopo non abbiamo enrico qui con
noi a sostituirlo c'è preda ciao fredda
ciao a tutti ragazzi se scopriamo da
soli il risultato di questo meraviglioso
kinder cereali gigante che nel frattempo
è così io vado a tagliare qua ora il
momento della verità è il pulsante rosso
adesso motivi breve quando saprai cosa
fa non vorrai ma secondo me che cosa
fare la campagna mi sapere che a me farà
del bene ea chiunque non sia in questo
momento in camera il male
io ci credo
questo
di etno non so se notate ma c'è una
differenza ovviamente fra questo e
questo a quadratini e disegnini
11 10 10 20 questa è la pace della gam
ha estorto vabbè dai sti cavoli non si
non sembra tranquillo tutti al riparo
cambia la professione ogni cinque minuti
gianmarco gli ho detto mi prendi questo
qui è tutto con la fiamma ossidrica
noi adesso che una fiamma ossidrica che
non sapevo che cazzo farci io proverò a
fare a questo punto le spighe mandara ke
sei hanno spiegato su colture
terrificante mi sono spiegato o no mi
sono già pentito di aver deciso di far
ed espira e spiegati a te cose si
costituì con spiga nichi era così vicky
bravo bravo
strano che non sta tenendo una merda
quel momento in cui la cucina buttata
tutto torna ed è una sensazione nuova
è finito abbiamo finito un kinder
cereali gigante a de vezze ancora qua di
carta
anche inversore ale gigante ragazzi
eppure il dietro che pure l'equipe
scenica
andate via bastava questo ma tu non
assaggi scusa
cioè tu hai fatto tutta sta manfrina
enac assaggi questo caso ci sono delle
cose che non mi convincono tipo questa
faglia di santa ma era quello che temevo
siete di un'antipatia
diciamo la verità guglielmo è
impossibile ok ci sono ecco
quanto partito cominciamo ma tieni un
bel perso dai
bilanci così sempre in borghese stavano
per caridi che schifo vai tu
il sapore non è cattivo a c'è qualcosa
nella consistenza veramente strano
non ho fatto niente tagliandolo si è
separata è lontano anni luce dall'essere
un kinder cereali non è che se ne metti
un po dei fiocchetti
bello a vedere ma meno ballarci bello ma
parlarci un lento stuff esattamente
quello statina riguadanti [ __ ]
fallimento deve essere molto più cremoso
l'interno
è una ricetta da dieci perché nella
società dell'apparenza l'aspetto visivo
è l'unica cosa che conta nella società
di oggi basta questo non conta il
contenuto sono le dimensioni che contano
e bassa la morale è che per youtube è un
contenuto da 10 per la vita perché
quella che è la quattro
porte in questo video vi sia piaciuto
lasciateci un like soprattutto
iscrivetevi al questo canale
noi ci vediamo domenica prossima con una
nuova puntata di cucina buttata